[Musique]
hologram alors autant savoir aujourd'hui
maroni aujourd'hui on découvre un
nouveau pack dispositif pour nos jeunes
le npa jc le nouveau pacte citoyen
justement je suis en route pour
rencontrer iphone qui a pu en bénéficier
allons à sa rencontre tard pour brest et
caen met à l'heure vous aussi le nouveau
pack jeune citoyen vous intéresse alors
suivez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici à la cellule d'insertion de
saint paul que nous allons retrouver
haifa après plusieurs démarches auprès
du département et la pub bénéficier du
nouveau pack jeune citoyen dans le cadre
d'une réinsertion professionnelle grâce
à ce dispositif volontariste du
département haifa a pu financer le
matériel et les tenues de travail dont
elle avait besoin pour suivre les
formations qui l'intéressait le
département l'a également aidé dans la
préparation 2 16 euros afin qu'elle
puisse obtenir son diplôme allez on va
tout de suite la rencontre est
alors tu as pu bénéficier du ntic
nouveau pack jeune citoyen dit nous
comment est-ce que ce dispositif a pu
t'aider à réaliser ses projets
professionnels mais gêne pas je citais
m'a aidé à fournir quelques projets que
j'avais en tête tels que la pâtisserie
et monfinancier aussi le permis de
conduire ils m'ont aidé à florian les
matériels qui était un peu trop cher de
quels sont les deux morts ce que tu as
dû effectuer pour avoir accès à ces
dispositifs qui les ai dit mon projet
mais ils m'ont aidé récemment j'ai passé
encore de police ads et du combat ils
m'ont aidé pour les oraux et maintenance
les tenues pro mais qu'est ce qui t'a
plu dans le logiciel j'aime bien par
rapportent qu'ils sont là un goûter et
une solution derrière directement que je
te souhaite une bonne continuation merci
alpha n'a rien
depuis 2014 le département grâce au
nouveau pack jeune citoyen permet à des
jeunes de plus de 16 ans rencontrant des
difficultés sociales ou professionnelles
de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
accompagnement afin de réaliser leurs
projets nous sommes ici la cellule
d'insertion de saint paul où nous
pouvons rencontrer des professionnels du
département qui mobilise le nouveau
paquet jeunes citoyens à l'anti nous qui
pour bénéficier de ce sont les jeunes
deux âgés de 16 à 29 ans révolus peuvent
en bénéficier il faut que le jeune soit
non scolarisés et en recherche
d'insertion sociale ou professionnelle
valentino qu en quatre mots qu'est ce
que le npd c'est alors l'heure pjc c'est
d'abord un manteau un accompagnement
renforcé et personnalisé et compte
actualiser qui va aider les jeunes dans
son parent prononciation professionnels
donc c'est un dispositif financier qui
permet de financer les matériels de
formation des équipements professionnels
les loisirs les comptes bancaires mais
aussi le pmi qui est nécessaire voire
sur un second des métiers ici dans dit
là ce sont des aides qui sont plafonnés
et qu'est ce que les jeunes apprécient
dans ce dispositif les jeunes à pau
après si l'accompagnement proposé par la
cellule insertion par l'innovation et
les maisons départementales nos équipes
sont disponibles et à l'écouté des
jeunes pour les aider à concrétiser leur
projet professionnel merci inclus merci
alexandre
[Musique]
grâce à cet accompagnement du
département les jeunes profitent d'un
vrai suivi pour la réalisation de leurs
projets arifin a été accompagné par un
conseiller tout au long de ses démarches
un suivi qui permet aux bénéficiaires
d'être informé le plus rapidement
possible sur l'avancée de leurs projets
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur le nouveau pack jeune
citoyen n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes
les coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini si vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les précédents rendez
vous sur nos sites et nos réseaux
sociaux quant à moi je vous retrouve
très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous irons à la
rencontre d'une personne qui a bénéficié
du cac par le capa est une aide qui
permet de faire des achats de produits
frais de produits pour nourrissons fait
dos et les produits d'hygiène
[Musique]